big night for the vegas gold knights
tonight it's game six with montreal and
a must win for the knights to stay alive
in the semifinals
so montreal leads the series 3-2 the
canadians took game five with a
convincing win at the fortress earlier
this week
both teams now back in montreal with
just five hours till backdrop
big part of playoffs you know whether
it's gaining momentum or
you know taking away momentum you know
it's always
something that you can rely on and want
to rely on but
you know it's struggling right now so um
just
you know trying to make it work and
not get too frustrated with it all right
so puck drops tonight at five in
montreal
there is a watch party happening at the
las vegas ballpark tonight
you can sit in the stadium seats or ride
on the diamond and catch the game on the
big screen there
those tickets cost five dollars kids
under two
are free so if the knights win game
seven will be back here in vegas
on saturday night at the fortress go
knight go